practiquemos un poco más esto de sumar y
restar números positivos o negativos
digamos que tenemos esta expresión 4 es
igual a menos 8 menos espacio en blanco
como siempre los invito a que pausa en
el vídeo y traten de resolver esto por
su cuenta y una vez que lo hayan hecho
continúen con el vídeo para ver cómo lo
resolvemos aquí que tenemos que restarle
al menos 8 para que esto sea igual a 4 a
4 positivo vamos a resolver los juntos y
para ayudarnos podría usar una recta
numérica que es la que tenemos aquí una
forma de resolverlo es comenzar con -8
esto es menos cinco menos seis menos
siete menos ocho quiero comenzar en
menos ocho y quiero hacerle algo a este
menos ocho para llegar a cuatro y este
cuatro es positivo así que es
1 2 3 4 quiero llegar acá que tengo que
hacer para ir de menos 8 hasta 4
positivo
bueno vemos que tengo que moverme hacia
la derecha 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 10 11 12
tengo que moverme a la derecha 12
espacios o lo que es lo mismo para pasar
de menos 8 a 4 tengo que sumar y
permítanme hacer un poquito más espacio
aquí tengo que sumar 12 otra forma de
verlo es que para llegar de menos 8 a 0
tengo que sumar 8 moverme 8 espacios a
la derecha y para llegar de 0 a 4 pues
tengo que moverme otros 4 lugares más a
la derecha así que es 84 pues nos da 12
pero como hacemos esto ya que nos está
diciendo que es menos 8 menos algo
normal
- pues que tenemos que restar para que
eso sea igual a 4 pues todo esto de aquí
queremos que termina siendo equivalente
a 12 positivo que podemos hacer aquí
pues restamos un negativo si restamos
menos 12 eso será equivalente a sumar 12
vamos a reescribir lo
4 es igual a menos 8
menos menos 12 o 12 negativos que pasa
cuando restamos un negativo pues termina
siendo sumar un número positivo esto es
lo mismo que tener menos 8 más 12
positivo o 4 es igual a menos 8 más 12
lo cual sabemos es correcto si a menos 8
le agregamos 8 para llegar a 0 y a esto
le agregamos otros cuatro positivos
llegamos a 4 positivo esto es bastante
interesante vamos a hacer otro problema
la práctica nunca va a estar demás ahora
tenemos un espacio vacío menos 2
negativo
igual a 7 negativos como analizamos esto
bueno pues lo primero que mi cerebro
quiere hacer es simplificar estos signos
esto de restar un negativo si restamos
uno menos dos va a ser lo mismo que es
sumar un 2 positivo esto va a ser
equivalente a tener un espacio en blanco
restando un 2 negativo es lo mismo que
tener la suma de un 2 positivo algo más
2 es igual a menos 7 y ahora voy a usar
mi recta numérica para analizar qué
tengo que hacer aquí está la recta
numérica
y mi meta es llegar a -7 aquí está menos
567 quiero llegar aquí y quiero
agregarle 2 a algo para llegar a menos 7
y si le agrego o sumo algo quiere decir
que me voy a estar moviendo hacia la
derecha así es como luce este + 2 en qué
número necesito comenzar para que al
saltar dos lugares hacia la derecha
llegue al menos 7 pues tengo que
comenzar dos lugares a la izquierda del
-7 12 si comienzo de aquí de menos 9 y
les 12
12 llegó al menos 7 pues este número ya
lo habíamos visto que es 2 a la
izquierda del -7 es menos 99 negativo
esto de aquí es menos 9 menos 92 si
comienzo en menos 9 y nos movemos los
lugares hacia la derecha llegaremos al
menos 7 o podemos decir que menos 9
menos menos 2 o 2 negativo es igual a
menos 7 ya que si restamos menos 2 nos
vamos a mover hacia la derecha si
restamos 2 positivos nos vamos a mover
hacia la izquierda pero si restamos
menos 2 nos vamos a mover hacia la
derecha por lo que llegaremos a menos 7
resolvamos un ejemplo más creo que me
estoy divirtiendo mucho con esto digamos
que tengo menos 4 que es igual a espacio
en blanco menos 9 y en lo que sacó mi
recta numérica pausa en el vídeo para
tratar de resolverlo por su cuenta aquí
tengo mi recta numérica pensemos en esto
nuestra meta es tomar algo
y restarle 9 para obtener menos 4
queremos obtener menos 4 aquí está el
menos 4 y de un número al que le
quitamos 9 nos debe de dar 4 otra forma
de ver esto de restar 9 es literalmente
mover los 9 lugares hacia la izquierda
123456789 así que debe haber un número
al que si le quitamos 9 vamos a llegar
al menos 4 este número que corresponde a
nuestro pasivo de aquí al cual le
restamos 9 y va a ser equivalente a
menos 4 no sabemos que el número
corresponde a este espacio vacío de acá
le debemos restar 9 y vamos a llegar al
menos 4 otra forma de ver esto es que
este número va a estar nueve lugares a
la derecha del -4 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 y es
5 positivo
veamos si estamos en lo correcto si
comenzamos en 5 positivo
movemos nueve lugares a la izquierda que
es lo mismo que restar nueve 123456789
efectivamente si le restamos nueve
llegamos al menos cuatro así que menos
cuatro es igual a 5 menos 9